what's up everybody thank you for
joining us at led live today we're going
to be talking about
what is the deception behind the movie
soul
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
so what's up everybody so glad to have
you here this friday
we have been getting comments after
comments this is where they pop up on
the screen pop
up everybody has been saying will you
guys cover soul
so man i don't think i've seen that many
recommendations for a movie in a long
time so there's got to be something to
this
so i actually started digging in and i
found some interesting things about this
movie so let's get right into it
first of all i want to talk about the
creator of the show he's also the cr
his name is pete docter with the er
doctor he's the creator of monsters inc
inside out up soul and maybe a couple
more
but this was interesting i found this on
wikipedia
it says during an interview in 2009
doctor confirmed
that he is a christian and said that it
influences his work however
he went on to say that he did not
envision himself ever creating a
christian movie
about about the relationship between his
faith and his filmmaking doctor says
i don't think people in any way shape or
form
like to be lectured to when people go to
a movie they want to see some sort of
experience of themselves
on the screen they don't come to be
taught
so in that sense and in terms of any
sort of beliefs
i don't want to feel as though i'm ever
lecturing
or putting an agenda forth wait what
no dude what i think is sad is christian
media already has
a difficult time like you look at
christian media it's always
cheesy low budget and this guy is an
amazing artist
you know he works for pixar and he's a
christian
and he doesn't want to use his talent
for the lord he literally says i don't
see myself making a christian movie it
seems like christians and film are the
most
disloyal people to their own faith and
he doesn't want to teach
but well i'm sure you'll develop into
the storyline of this but it's
completely opposite of
christ but it's sad that
that here's somebody with so much
creativity and
a megaphone you know has a platform
for people to learn something with and i
remember watching those clips of
of george lucas and and him talking
about hey anybody in the media knows
that you you've got a microphone and
you've got a platform
you're teaching somebody something what
is it that you're teaching them so even
though he's
sitting there going well i don't want to
teach him christianity well
if you're not teaching them christianity
then what are you teaching them because
i kind of view a lot of what
is coming out of hollywood in two ways
it either leads you closer to god
or it's leading you away if it's not
even
speaking of any sort of religious ideas
but it's just wasting your time well
then
you could have probably done something
better with your time and and he said
i don't he doesn't envision himself
creating a christian movie that means
he could do it on the side but he's not
even no i don't want to use my talent
for god
and also what i think is is kind of
interesting too is it's like you know
they're so scared to teach christianity
but there is a lot of people who
don't believe in christianity and teach
and they're putting those things
in there purposefully whether it be the
names or
you know the concepts that are behind
there i mean like you know even george
lucas was like look i wrote star wars
off of reading carl jung's
stuff you know or um you know some of
these guys who aren't
open gnostics so it's interesting
what do you got keith i'm just like over
here
i find this so interesting because um
i'll probably bring a lot of more out of
this later but if you just like scroll
through pixar's web page for this whole
film
it actually has quite a bit on there
more than i've seen for other films
and i i just want to read one one
comment that i think will
set the tone for this whole thing
you go down to the section on the web
page and it's about
it says lost souls and here it says and
i think this is coming from the director
pete doctor some people get caught up in
something that
isn't necessarily bad cooking
video games art okay says director pete
doctor
but if you do it to the exclusion of
everything else in your life
you might become a lost soul yeah that's
actually
something in the movie i do want to
bring this out um
before we start just tearing into it
because i know people are gonna
you guys missed the whole point no i
didn't miss the point every deception
all propaganda is wrapped up in
something that you can identify with
that you can accept
in this movie the whole kind of
plot of the story is um enjoy the little
things in life don't
don't focus on i wish i could just be
the biggest musician in this guy's case
you know he was a
music teacher for an elementary school
or something middle school teacher
and he just feels like you know it's all
right i'm doing music but i really want
to be like a famous
jazz musician so he feels like in this
limbo space
and what he ends up finding out at the
end is you know
don't focus so much on trying to reach
that an unobtainable goal
just live in the moment live in life if
enjoy
being a father enjoy watching the leaves
fall you know take a look
i i agree with that yeah those are good
kind of there's nothing wrong with that
it's the little deceptions that are
thrown out it's the little bit of eye
dropper of cyanide in that glass of ice
cold lemonade yeah
because the devil's not going to throw
into a a box full of only error because
then everybody would just reject it
so always there's these truths that are
wrapped up
in there and and to me they they they
are even more dangerous
the closer they are to those truths yep
which is why satan loves that tactic
so here's here's the pete doctor
on rolling stone just listen to this
clip right here the first challenge was
not pissing off half the world's
population because you know there are
obviously a lot of different ideas about
what happens after we
die so we decided well actually what's
good about this idea is that it doesn't
really need to get into that we did
explore it a little bit but
primarily the movie takes place before
life so before
we're born and there are very few
traditions actually that talk about that
so then we get to make it up but then um
the challenge with that of course is
there's very little to look at
for reference we did do a lot of
research we talked to
rabbis and priests and buddhists and all
sorts of folks just
to learn what we could but um you know
most people said you know the
souls are ethereal ethereal they're
non-physical they're invisible
um not very helpful in terms of hints
for how to design things
so what i think is interesting is he's a
christian he doesn't make anybody mad by
putting his own
beliefs in there but let's talk to every
other
religion in the world and let's throw a
little bit of that into this
one thing i noticed okay so technically
this isn't heaven is this heaven
no is it h e double hockey sticks
hell how hell quiet coyotes
no it's the great before called the
great before it's not the great beyond
that's the destination where you go when
you die but this is the great before we
were
all once there as spirit ghost beings
living in a perfect world that's very
much like heaven
and you're there with these counselors
who are trying to
help you find your niche before they
send your personality down to earth and
you become
a human being and we'll get into the
belief systems that do believe that but
one thing muhammad ali was one of the
mentors muhammad ali is
of this movie yeah i mean it's just
these short clips you see um
22 is being mentored by certain people
so these are people
who were like really accomplished in
life they died so they get to mentor
people before they come to earth oh
gotcha in this storyline not actually
real muhammad he was okay mentoring the
storyline no he's been dead for a while
and you want to explain what 20 or who
22 is
so so 22 basically is
a pre-born spirit soul whatever you want
to call it i guess they're using the
word soul
and she just can't find her niche
anywhere i don't like this i don't like
that honestly i don't even want to go to
earth because it looks boring and
painful and
i'd rather just stay here so she lets
these mentors like
try to convince her of why they should
why she should go and she's just like
no i'm not going so she's been up here
like way longer than anybody
else but what i wanted to bring out was
muhammad ali
is a muslim so a muslim is in this
world and then carl young
who's a swiss psychologist and
psychiatrist he's in this world so
you know if if we're talking about like
this heavenly world
are we saying that all religions get to
go to this place
yeah and and i mean i don't know if
you're going to get into this who
carl young is well yeah i'll talk a
little bit about it so on
phyllis sofizer website young
on religion and a summary of his
religious experience and beliefs this is
what he said
the devil is a personification of the
repressed
aspects of the human psyche young wanted
to include
the shadow of the the shadow in the
godhead
the trinity needs to be transformed into
a quaternary
so four parts if we are to speak the
wholeness of god
the figure of jesus christ is a symbol
of the self
jesus christ exemplifies the archetype
young found a perfect christ meaningless
if christ was perfect he could not be
whole
to be whole or holy a person must
reintegrate the shadow side of their
personality
if the antichrist is not recognized
within
it will appear externally in a
malevolent
form okay that was a lot so what he's
saying is
you can't be whole unless you have
darkness in you it's the whole yin yang
philosophy
and it's why um star wars was so
attracted to his writing
and there's a lot of this blending of
the the light and the darkness
carl jung is basically the father of
modern um gnosticism
in fact a lot of people kind of followed
his writings and his work
and then continued that forward um and a
lot of people in hollywood
are very familiar with his work but he's
taking the concepts of
the bible and good and evil and god and
satan and all this kind of stuff and
he's just
blending it and mixing it and and so
that's where we see this pattern
if if certain directors are really into
his writing or certain writers are
really into his writing
we're seeing this pattern of them making
god a villain
the devil the good guy and we're seeing
this over and over and over again so
are they saying that there's something
wrong with just jesus and his life
because of his perfection i mean
isn't that kind of a misconception it's
not like christ was removed from
the hardships of this life so gnosticism
basically also teaches that
you are created in a world that is sort
of confined around you
and it's your job to break away from
that world so even in jesus's case they
won't deny the
actual existence of jesus what they'll
do is be like well he just
ascended outside of this confinement
that he had
and was able to resurrect and you know
all this kind of christ consciousness
yeah so they
spin it in in a way that it's like
fitting into their gnostic
views i was sitting there thinking about
this idea that if he's perfect he could
not be made whole
you have jesus all the time offering to
people while he's on this earth do you
want to be made well
and if you know a little bit about greek
you know that word
that it's talking about um whether it's
be made well or
saved or whatever comes from a greek
word called the sozo
which means wholeness it's salvation
it's it's a complete and total
healing it is to be made whole
and so he i mean obviously doesn't
understand
the bible or what the bible is teaching
to say that you know if he was person
he couldn't be made whole i mean if he
would if he was not perfect he couldn't
make
any of us perfect so now i also
also kind of have on this basis of this
concept that you have these little beans
that are
try trying to have these influencers
that are trying to
to push them down to the earth and
and give them this sort of character or
personality or something like this right
that's placing the blame on who oh my
god
that's placing the blame on hey i wasn't
the one that chose this so
if i came down to earth and i'm a thief
then it's not my fault because
these guys taught me that or showed me
that so i think once again it's always
shoveling this this
blame off of the moral self and um
not getting to the bottom of it that
we're sinners and and savior
i was seeing sort of like reincarnation
type of vibe because these mentors that
are taking these
souls or spirits along with them they're
passing through
their mentors lives like they're in conf
they're confined to their
it's my life earth sounds dumb i've had
thousands of mentors who failed and now
hate me
risa i have compassion for every soul
except you i don't like you copernicus
the world doesn't
revolve around you 22 muhammad ali you
are the greatest
pain in the butt maria antoinette nobody
can help you
nobody and so muhammad ali he takes the
soul with him and he's like okay look at
boxing look what i've done i'm the
greatest and now
this person comes back to earth and they
have this mindset
of muhammad ali correct i'm the greatest
exactly are you ever going to be in
heaven and be like i'm so much better
than you
are you ever going to be like that never
like just that concept alone is not a
heavenly concept yeah
so these the beings are like these ai
things called terry
that are i guess guiding
yeah jerry and terry that are guiding
these little souls it seems like the
creation of them are so like haphazard
like oh i'll give you this personality
and yeah you five have this personality
it's like there's no
real thought to it and it's just totally
contradictory of
god and his love for us now he knit us
in our mother's womb and he was
very intentional about our creation and
he has purpose for us and
you know what i mean so so if if god has
purpose and intention for us and we
deviate from that
i can just see that as those lies all
the way back well god you gave me this
woman god you created the snake
your it's your problem and that just
seems to be um
satan's big mo it's not it's not his
problem it's somebody else's problem
and and carl young is teaching a
religious
perspective like like that is it so if
they're basing it off of that isn't that
interesting that
a christian would not be like hey i'm
going to kind of put some concepts that
paul was trying to teach in the new
testament in here
it's like no i'm going to go straight to
the other side and put
that in the story line yeah well
you know i don't i'm not saying that he
took any of his
creative writing from this guy but what
the point i was making was
these mentors all go to the great beyond
now
most of this is taking place in the
great before but
these mentors they're on their way to
the great beyond they've died
and they have to kind of mentor somebody
and then they go to great beyond so
they're on their way to heaven carl
young
muhammad ali who's a muslim so
it's this whole universalism
yeah which is basically the teaching
that it doesn't matter what you do
everybody here
everyone's going to go to heaven yeah
and and really you're just going through
the motion of this
but in the end everybody's going to
learn a lesson and make it there in the
in the end
so let me ask a query clarifying
question because i haven't seen this
um they're supposed to mentor somebody
to get to the great beyond to this
heaven
what determines that is it just like as
long as they mentor somebody they
automatically go
basically really so but
what is it that
i guess corrects their prior
understanding of what they did on this
earth
because here here you know you're you're
setting these people up as role models
but you're also saying the way they were
is the way they should be and that's
what they're
going to use to influence everybody else
so in my mind
nothing's getting any better yeah yeah
that's right
all right you just keep staying at the
bottom rung
all the time and i'm looking at this
pixar page and i'm kind of you know
going through and i'm like okay
they're talking about the different
places in here there's a place called
the
astral plane that's so new age
no i'm like really so i mean what is the
astral plane and
you can quickly pull up you know
articles about this and it's
a plane of existence this is ours
definition
no but it's from classical and medieval
oriental esoteric philosophies i mean
uh people it was popularized by
theosophy
which is you know blavatsky um
it talks here about alice bailey writing
about it
and just all these different types of
religions
and most of them though i mean it's
clearly very like
found in hermetic and gnostic sex
and just like almost everything but
christianity
which is what i think's sad about this
movie this this christian says he'll
never make a christian film and i'm not
going to
lecture people and teach people but
there's not a shred of christianity in
here and
most of it is gnostic or new age or
something else but what's the point
because
matthew 28 right what does it say go ye
therefore and make disciples
of all nations like as a christian what
are you supposed to do
you are supposed to teach that's part of
that commission
to go and to teach and to baptize to
disciple right you're
you're supposed to be doing all of that
so if you come at
your life's work which is what this is
it's his life's work to make films and
you're like
eh let's just forget that part yeah
i mean what else is there
it's really sad so when the main
character dies
his name's joe gardner he he finally
gets his big break
he's like gonna be a replacement for
somebody at a jazz
uh show and he gets the call and he
falls down a manhole
and immediately dies like he falls down
he drops
and he turns into this blue ghost or
whatever so all he wants to do is like
no i can't go to the great beyond i
gotta get back to earth i gotta
i gotta do this thing which is what we
see in the movie uh
all dogs go to heaven right cause i
don't wanna die welcome to
doing whatever you do you got the wrong
guy
he goes to heaven he's like no i gotta
go back to everything he's running away
from the light and they're like
you can never come back and all this so
he wants to get back to earth and nobody
wants to send him back the earth
no you got to do this thing you got a
mentor and they give him 22
who's the one who doesn't want to go to
earth so they kind of like team up well
okay you want you want to go back there
remember he took someone's place he
wasn't supposed to be a mentor oh yeah
yeah
well it was an accident but he ends up
being connected with 22
and she doesn't want to go to earth and
he wants to go to earth so let's let's
help each other out
and she's like i'm going to show you
these mystics they literally call them
mystics
i'm going to lead you to these mystics
that i know they can help you get back
to your body and his name is moon wind
and here you see him
very hippie-like and he's doing yeah
yoga pose doing the mudras
and you see it all through the movie and
the disney fandom
says that his goal is to help souls find
human bodies
so that's not just like my
interpretation that's his goal it
he helps souls find their human bodies
back on earth
so here's the other mystics that are
with them and this one here
is always in the lotus pose doing the
hand mudras and floating
levitating everywhere he goes new age
big time
and then when he finally gets to the
part the guy gets moon
moon wins says come here or whatever and
he's like
um he's going to open a portal and send
him back to his body
so how does he do it look the closed
caption that's actually on the screen i
didn't type this
he says breathe into your crown chakra
he's telling the main character breathe
into your crown chakra
then he's doing the mudra with both
hands they're both got their eyes closed
and then the portal starts to open and
when he opens his eyes he goes no
peeking
maintain your meditative state
this guy has the power to open up a
portal and send you back to your body
but you have to
open you have to breathe into your crown
chakra and stay in a meditative state
and here's the scene where
the the portal opens up and he gets he
gets to get what he wants
so in layman's terms right what i'm
hearing from you
is as a kid is gonna watch this thing
and kids are kind of aware of the
concept of heaven you'd probably go to
most kids and say
you know hey do you know what heaven is
or
or would you like to go there and a
kid's probably going to be like yeah
so the seed that's planted in some kid's
mind is if i want to get there i need to
go talk to somebody with these qualities
and what's scary about that is that you
distill down that new age
belief system and it's all esoteric
knowledge that gets you to a higher
existence
minus god no you know what i mean and i
just want to make a point that
he's not just some random character in
the background he's like
he's the one that's helping him he's the
one that does get him back to his body
so he is like a main focus in this movie
without this guy
the main character would never get to go
back to his body right
and so there's even a toy of this guy
and it's just a straight-up yoga pose
and uh he's actually got a clear base
that makes him levitate
so despite all these different people
from all these different religions being
up in this place
it's kind of run the main religion is
this esoteric religion do you find that
interesting
yeah the new age yeah and the astral
philosophy and all that yeah
and at some point i don't remember how
it happened but they
they do get to earth and uh they they've
switched bodies 22
and the main character of like the main
character joe is inside of a cat
now and 22 is inside the main character
joe's body
but moon wind is here in the physical
i'm not sure how that happened but i
don't know if he can be in two places at
once or what but
moon wind is a sign spinner on earth
and he's like well i can get you back in
your body and he
sits down cross-legged and he sets up
candles and he opens a book
like this is a cult man and like they
just act like it's a joke or something
well isn't it funny that they fight so
heavily against i don't want anything
christian it don't put your christian
stamp on it don't do this right
but it's like you can put buddhism in it
you can put new age in it you can put
all these other religions and
nobody's raising arms and going like
what i don't i don't want my kid
learning that
right i don't hear that on the internet
we're probably one lone voice
at the corner of the internet that even
has a problem with this and
and really i think it boils all the way
back down to what is this teaching us
that that is not in line with my
christian belief yeah if you're watching
harry potter or
my little pony or all these things that
are blatantly teaching you witchcraft
that's a religion if you're watching
this and it's teaching you
new age philosophy that's a religion and
this christian has made this movie
saying i don't want to put my beliefs in
there
but i'm basically going to make a piece
of new age propaganda for your children
there's a there's a fundamental point i
think that people
grossly misunderstand and that is
i can be presented with lots of
different information
and because
i believe that i am a intelligent human
being
i have the ability to sift through the
information
and be discerning
if you are a christian you
are you should be aware with what
happened in a garden of eden
and i think that's where that idea
becomes a very big
problem and the reason i say that is
eve was a perfect
created being
and she had never been lied to
and she had to
at some point discern between
conflicting
information
perfect being super intelligent
probably used 100 of her brain yeah
made the wrong choice yeah so
how much more on guard
do we need to be and and yeah you're
you're going there
the fundamental point was she made the
wrong choice
because she said well i have different
information
and i have the word of god i'll choose
the different information
instead of the word of god and it's the
same exact ground that we're being
brought over
every time we have to make these choices
do i choose the word of god or do i
choose the other information and we're
living in a day and age where we're
being
bombarded with information on all sides
and it's conflicting with the word of
god they're looking for a way of to
eternal life
if you really think of the end
conclusion of where they're going right
that that that's where the disciples in
in john 14
verse 5 says thomas said unto him lord
we don't know where you're going
how can we know the way this is where
john 14 6
says jesus said unto him i am the way
the truth and the life
no man cometh to the father but by me
if you're claiming that there's any
other route to get
to that end goal or that place which is
literally that's the end goal to get to
heaven to see the father
and be that the only door is jesus and
if that concept doesn't come through
man the whole thing on that one point is
worthless
i mean that that goes in so many
different directions too because
if you're saying there are multiple ways
again now you're now you're in conflict
with or
the word of god those two ideas can't
both be true
one of them's a liar is jesus alive and
if the word of god is not lying that
means
this other system is a liar and
multiple times the bible says multiple
times even in revelation
there will not enter into into heaven
anything that makes or loves a lie
but it's interesting the christians
justification of that because they'll
use the lie
to open up conversation for the truth
like i'm looking at this article and it
says
soul will give your family fun
opportunities to talk about god
which god whoa yeah you know right so
it'll give you i mean let me tell you
why all this is wrong
and we start from the top just to bounce
off what you're saying about you know i
can decipher this stuff
and i'm not going to be influenced yet
eve was
look at the christian church today how
many how many of those christians are
going to yoga class how many of those
christians are playing with angel boards
instead of ouija boards and angel cards
instead of tarot cards man that church
is being
so deceived and it's because of the
media makes everything look so
acceptable and mainstream and oh it's
not evil look
everybody does it that it's
desensitization
it's propaganda yeah and you know i
i i would like to give people more
credit than that
um you know i don't want to just beat up
on everybody
that's out there or watching or may come
across this program
you're only going to know as much truth
as you absorb
so are you reading your bible every
single day
are you going to a church that teaches
bible-based teachings you know are you
in
some kind of study group how is your
prayer life you know
all those things add up and if in your
christian experience you just find
you know the bible's boring i'd rather
you know i can go to
church on whatever morning and listen to
a feel-good message and walk away
and you know then i'm gonna go out to
eat after that
and you know whatever at night and
and god isn't really part of your
daily existence if he's not integrated
into your life
then it's going to easy
it's going to be easy to drift away and
so you you may not
be aware i mean you may be going to yoga
class because
i mean the world is going a particular
direction all your friends are
doing one thing you don't see anything
wrong with it they're good people
but if you're not reading and studying
and looking into these things how would
you know
no you know and as a child who has no
idea
if you have a floating line of what
truth is meaning
you're reading this okay i understand
the bible has a lot of truth in it
but i'm reading carl jung i'm reading
this over here i'm reading that
and they're saying conflicting things
together how do you then distinguish
what's
what's real and what's not when that
conflict happens who are you
going with in that case and i think you
know
like we always do on this channel we're
speaking to the christian
look if you're not a christian this is
not the conversation to begin with
you know what i i know you say that but
there are a lot of people that we found
that that are watching this show and
they're not
christian and they've been communicating
with and responding to us you know and
you
you think of uh daniel wasn't really
a christian i mean and he you know he
came around so
as much as we say we're talking to the
christian at the same time if you're an
atheist and you're listening
you know i don't want you to feel like
we're not talking to you too i mean we
are in a way
this this is true i just mean there's a
different starting block yeah
different starting point and you know
there's some concepts that i think
we would need to build up or i would
hope that somebody that doesn't share
these same sort of beliefs
would say how are you getting to that
yeah and i want to see where your logic
is coming from
and so we i mean we challenged all of
the listeners if you guys are out there
listening
um you know and you disagree with us why
don't you pick up a bible
and why don't you kind of search out
some of these these topics and try to
get to the bottom of this
if you need some some guidance on that i
mean by all means ask us
we love to engage and we're constantly
trying to share
information and hey yeah check this
bible verse out and and
shoot if we have a bible study on this
topic
we'll send that to you if you want so
yeah and that's that's the first thing i
tell anybody that when somebody says
something to me that
i don't believe in according to the
bible or that they say
well you know what about this thing or
that thing i'm like show me the verse
that's the first thing just show me the
verse if you show me the verse i'll
believe
it but then i say well this is what i
see in this verse and this verse and
this verse and this verse
and and i i put all that evidence on the
balances and where there's a majority of
you know line upon line precipitant
precept
out of the mouth of two or three
witnesses you can't build a whole
foundation out of one verse
and and so if i have this much weight
over here but it's like well there's
these two verses that say this
i'm not gonna base my theology on this
i'm going to study why does it say that
why
because the god's word doesn't
contradict itself i also want to say
this because
um you know we we do engage with people
who who
disagree vehemently with with whatever
angle we're kind of coming at this kind
of stuff
if you have a real heart for truth and
you open your heart to god
it doesn't matter what we say we're
giving our our perspective and our
opinion but at the end of the day if
you're coming to god saying god i want
to understand this topic
show me the truth i guarantee you god is
not going to ignore you
and so you know always come to god with
whatever you're learning from whatever
youtube christian channel or whatever
you're watching
and and literally just god show me the
truth in this show me the truth in this
and i believe he will direct your past
yeah and i i think i would add a
clarified
to that and that is show me the truth in
your word
there you go because there's a lot of
people who take the approach
of like well i'll pray about it as if
prayer exempts you from what the bible
says
when i prayed in this video
recommendation popped up and i clicked
it i believe what it said as a sign or
something
right that's true because how did jesus
beat the devil
in the first place constantly with the
word of god and
and then the devil once he caught on
write a quick write the first time that
jesus
answered back with some scripture what'd
the devil do
scripture oh yeah you want to play that
game two can play with that game
and and he quoted a scripture that
literally was in the bible
but the way that he was um using it and
and
and the tone and everything that he was
coming at
really was putting a a emphasis in a
wrong spot
so this is just a scene of what the
movie's about
what this the great before is all about
you see all these little blue dots and
they're falling down
to earth this is this is what that's all
about i wanted to go back to a point
that you made you were wondering if the
science filler spinner was in two
different places well he was actually in
the zone so he's human he's not
dead he's human but he is in the zone
and that's where people's souls go
when they get really into music or
sports or that's interesting or
meditation
yeah so i'm thinking with what are you
what are you saying so if
i'm in the united states and someone's
in china and we meditate we can meet up
in this
zone and have conversations
that actually right there is is them
putting a little piece of truth out
where they're saying like
look music is a spiritual experience
music is a spiritual experience and it
is
it is and so if you're entering in and
going whatever dude i just like this
type of music and it doesn't matter what
it is like it doesn't matter lyrics
doesn't matter beat has nothing to do
with that you go talk to any musician
and they will tell you it is a spiritual
experience and i you know i used to
i was at a place where i thought as long
as i had christian lyrics it's okay and
everything
but the more i studied it out and
music has its own spirit to it you can
listen to
don't no no no no don't that's not happy
music that's not something that makes
you want to skip around
but when you hear la la la la la la la
you know there's certain things
kids music makes kids want to march
around dance around there's other music
that makes you fearful
no matter what's on the screen it could
be zooming in
on a cat and it's like ton ton ton and
you're going to
feel fear or panic or whatever and in
the bible
just to use scripture to or was our
foundation
king saul he was a king right king david
yeah king saul
was feeling depressed and had this
evil spirit in him and they called david
to come play his harp and when he played
the harp no lyrics
when he played the harp the spirit left
saul
and he was and he wasn't playing head
banger music yeah
no i'm sure it was very melodically
lovely when you look at a lot of metal
and these days even rap you see
occult imagery all over it so they're
telling you what spirit they have
so guys pixar is kids entertainment
right
i mean a lot of stuff
that's made anymore um is made
for both both what children and adults
i think this is one of the most cleverly
designed
genres of filmmaking because it is
on this on the outside packaging wrapper
of of it
if you would is kid-friendly but
they are constantly putting adult
orientated things that go right over the
tops of kids heads
and it's aimed at the adult um
conversation and so
i think that it's a very wide range
where people will say oh no
this is just for kids but it actually is
a adult orientated thing
yeah it i mean stories are powerful
ways to share with people and that's
what jesus did
and so jesus when he told a story he had
a story that
you know if you were at a a child's
level you could understand it at its as
its basic meaning
but if you were a little older than that
you could understand it at a greater
meaning
give you an example you know there are
multiple times where jesus was talking
to the
pharisees he'd use a parable like of a
man who owned a vineyard and lent it out
and a child might be listening and get
so much out of it but the pharisees were
listening they were like
knew exactly who he was talking about
like
this parable is about us it's not just
like this some general story that
happened
to teach this lesson no this is about me
it's about us so they can have these
these multiple levels
and i think it's the same with these you
know they can have
layers of meaning with the people
they're crafting just because a kid
doesn't understand doesn't mean that
they forget so as time goes
right click that illustration is you'll
watch into that mind
over and over again and then and then
it's like the same sort of thing
these kind of concepts such as new age
are brought up
in a very subtle way i mean sometimes
this is not so subtle
go to the chakra you know this will do
this right that's not very subtle to me
but the way that that's brought up will
then be reinforced later on in adult or
adult movies and then when you get older
they just get the full-blown deception
you know like here you go
but i think that that it starts back
here plants the seed
that seed is familiar to those children
as they grow
it becomes this greater thing but think
about what god is doing as well
why do we teach kids the simple stories
of jonah
noah all of these things right because
those simple
ideas of faith and what that builds on
then we build with more complex
understandings
as we grow older and more mature in the
faith and
and most kids they grow up
with the simple concept which is was
actually it's probably the most profound
concept throughout the whole bible that
that god loves them you know this is the
idea that you
you wean children on you raise them on
and
and often times that's why they come
back because they remember they were
taught as a young child
god loves me you know and that's what is
helps break through to them if they
drift sometime
down the road as an adult and you know
they go in this crazy way they come back
he's
you know what i remember god loved me
so i want to share this excerpt with you
guys from an article the title is
soul will probably confuse your kids
and it might confuse you at times too
this movie goes after extremely complex
themes and its characters and settings
can get quite abstract as we
saw he showed a photo many photos the
movie
wants to leave its audiences asking
questions about the meaning of life
the human experience what it means to be
you
whether or not your life's purpose
should be your soul quest in life
and what it means to be truly fulfilled
but you know he's not trying to teach
anything right
okay so the setting takes you through
places like the great beyond which is
seemingly post-death
the great before where souls get their
personalities and their
spark the zone and we discuss that
that's where people
go when they're really getting into um
music or sports et cetera
the astral plane and it seems like at
least some of the characters
can transverse these planes of existence
at will
so moon wind exactly so it gets pretty
trippy
so don't be surprised if your kids will
walk out of the movie with 100 questions
and you feel like you can only answer
two of them okay i'll read that again
so don't be surprised if your kids walk
out of the movie with 100 questions and
you feel like you can only
answer two of them now talk about
babylon i actually have a friend
and her younger brother who was like 10
actually couldn't finish the movie he
was like so disinterested and got bored
and confused he's like okay i'm done
with this
but yeah kids who got to the end of the
movie and have all these questions and
now they're in their parents face like
what does this mean what's that i mean
what's the astral plane like
can i talk to my friend by going into my
mind like
now as a christian parent how do you if
that's like two steps back or behind or
trying to
play catch up with your child i just
want to say to the people that say
oh it doesn't affect me and it doesn't
matter and all that like
there's so much power in this why
why are certain cartoons banned because
there was black face in it or something
right
that's a good question why why do the
lgbt community want so much
representation
well there's all you show is
heterosexual relationships with a king
and a queen a princess and a prince
if it didn't matter and it doesn't
affect you then why ban the blackface
why one lgbt and all that you know
this stuff does affect you it does have
an influence it does
have some kind of agenda or story or
whatever that is going to uh
you know it's going to go into your mind
i i know that they're getting at
like this core question of what is what
is your real purpose in life
right but when you go back to the bible
and you use that as your foundation
jeremiah 29 11 says for i know the plans
i have for you declares the lord plans
for you
plans to prosper you and not to harm you
to give you hope and a future amen
that's plans for everyone that's not
just like oh
a random few i have plans for so if
god's got a plan for you
and you're not following that then
you're listening to the enemy well that
annihilates predestination right there
so let's check out this clip real quick
is this heavens no
it's the great before this is where new
souls get their personalities quirks and
interests before they go to earth
meet 22. i don't want to go to earth
stop fighting this i don't wanna
okay look i already know everything
about earth and i don't want anything to
do with it you're missing out on the
joys of life
like uh pizza i can't smell
we can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body
no smell no taste or touch see
okay i get it you caught how everybody
is like this pre-existent
soul with a personality and all that and
then you get sent to earth
i want to show you who believes that
this is
i looked up pre-existent and i looked it
up on wikipedia
and it says is a belief that each
individual human soul existed before
mortal conception
and at some point before birth enters or
is placed into the body
concepts of pre-existence can encompass
either the belief that the soul came
into existence at some time
prior to conception or the belief that
the soul is eternal
alternative positions are traduciaism
and creationism so these are alternative
positions
which both hold that the individual
human soul does not come into existence
until conception
it is to be distinguished from
pre-formation which is about
physical existence and applies to all
living things
ancient greek thought and islam
affirm a pre-existence but is generally
denied in christianity
but here's a christian sect that does
believe it
this comes straight off of the church of
jesus christ of latter-day saints
look at their video where did we come
from
we lived with god as spirits before we
came to earth
we call this our pre-mortal life
god our heavenly father is the father of
our spirits
we are all brothers and sisters and part
of his family
next we came here to earth so why are we
here
coming here was part of god's plan of
happiness
first we came to get a physical body
when we came to this world our spirit
joined together with the body to
experience all the joy that heavenly
father wants us to have
we need to have a physical body i
believe that we need to have a physical
body god wants us to have a physical
body
but i do not believe that we used to be
some kind of
spirit conscious out in heaven with the
father before we existed
but in that clip we watched he was
trying to convince 22 who's a
pre-existent
soul why she should go to earth why you
should
leave this perfect place
and come to earth i think in in a
strange way this also diminishes the
the gift that jesus came down to this
earth you know what i mean
like this immaculate conception type of
of coming from
somewhere else and then being existing
before
and you know it says jesus
was with the father before right so
it doesn't say everyone was i i don't
know if one verse that actually even
says any of that the verse that they use
the one that i
saw on that video they say i knew you
before you were in the womb
oh we were friends with god before in
the whims but god that's tricky
yes it is tricky but but god knowing us
and being able to look down through the
portal he's not he's not designed
yeah exactly not confined by the portal
of time so he
sees that there is a beam that will
exist at this point i mean that's what
prophecy does right
there's there's people that i know jesus
but i've never
seen him you know that's right and you
know there's there's a lot of things
that that
you can't say that just because of that
concept of saying i knew you before
all of a sudden means that everyone has
always existed also i don't know
if i can reconcile that because if we
had consciousness before
connecting with our earthly bodies that
means we were aware of the other options
that are out there as well
so this could be viewed as a punishment
if you kind of catch my drift don't know
if this should be added
in the episode but there are other
worlds out there with other beings god
created
things before earth so if we're all in
this
what is it the great before place and
then god is like okay you guys are going
to go to earth you're like no well we
want to go to this place that
isn't fallen that is still perfect why
are we trapped here and some people
might ask where you get that from
but there's at least two verses in the
bible that talk about god forming the
world's
plural so i'm like sitting here
wondering about this whole thing like
what's what's the point like what's to
gain you have this pre-existence and
then
then like you have to go to earth like
why
and then you have no recollection no
recollection of the pre-existence what's
the point of that go to the great
hereafter or whatever it's called do you
get a body or not
well i don't know muhammad and them
didn't have it but maybe once they we
never actually get to see the great
beyond i i guess you know thinking about
it from a biblical perspective
the reason that we're here and the
reason we're looking forward to heaven
is because plan a didn't work
you know otherwise there would have
never been a need for a heaven
god created the earth perfect he created
the human beings perfect
and that would have continued on in
perfection
like heaven it's only because of sin
that we're looking forward to a heaven
because we're trying to get back to you
that perfection that god created
back to the wholeness the zozo yeah yeah
i like that you brought that up leaving
perspective
perfection to come to this nasty earth
to go back to perfection
like i'm in eden but i'd rather go here
so that's why i asked is there a gnostic
plot i want to look at some of the
characters
joe gardner so his name is joe which is
just like your average whatever
joe his last name is gardner and i
looked it up
it's literally keeper of the garden
which makes me think of the verse
where god is telling adam that he's the
gardener
and the lord god took the man and put
him into the garden of eden to dress it
and to keep it that's
genesis 2 15. so if we want to look at
this
through like a gnostic lens he's
you know he's like adam who had a
pre-existence
in a perfect world but he keeps wanting
to go to this earth he's even trying to
convince
22 to leave that perfect paradise that
she's in
and come to earth and when you
die or no not not when you die when
you're in the
great before it's so confusing in the
great before there's these people
they're called counselors
i'm not i'm not using that word they're
called counselors
and their names are jerry and terry and
jerry is um multiple people but as one
really yeah this is what the background
says on the um
the fandom the counselors at the great
before
there are a number of them are all known
as jerry
cheery optimistic and mostly all-knowing
the ubiquitous counselors run the youth
seminar
so they're ubiquitous they're it's like
uh what's the word omnipresent
this one being but in different places
teaching different people
and so i'm looking at proverbs 15 3 it
says
the eyes of the lord are in every place
beholding the evil and the good
so they might not call this heaven but
when i watched
behind the scenes they said it was like
this perfect world where there's no
sharp edges everything's kind of round
and
and fluffy and um you know it's
in the in it if you line it up with
mormonism and stuff it is a pre-existent
you live there as a pre-existent being
before you come to earth
so it's very much like heaven so
the counselors are the great before the
one's name is jerry in the hebrew it
means may jehovah
exalt so this is someone lifted up and
in the greek it means
sacred name so i mean who has a sacred
name right that no one would speak
and if they wrote it wrong they'd burn
the whole paper and everything
so this ubiquitous person who's cheery
and all-knowing and
you know all-seeing is the jerry
and then there's the terry person who in
the greek
means harvester or reaper so it makes me
think of matthew 9 38 where it says
pray therefore the lord of the harvest
that he will send forth laborers into
his harvest
so to me this very much looks like god
in heaven with in a perfect paradise
why would you leave the perfect world
you know his name wasn't tom
right i mean you you you couldn't make a
point
with that but the fact that you can sit
there and look at a name like that and
be like wow there's some awful
similarities to god now that could be
sheer coincidence let's
just say for for hypothetical sense that
that was just randomly chosen
yeah but if it wasn't randomly chosen i
find that very interesting
yeah so according to this film soul
when does life begin when you get to
earth
begins at earth and when does life end
well the real freedom of
life are we going to talk about abortion
no
no but really like yeah if if you have
this consciousness
and your personality even develops and
all of that before you even
reach conception good point right
according to this
yeah and he's not wanting to offend
anyone so this should be well received
by
the large majority of people right and
then when does life end so apparently
although you're dead you still have this
duty or job to do
in the afterlife before you go into the
great beyond so is there anything that
basically
causes you to cease to exist was there
anything in here that was basically like
always if you choose the wrong then
you you're not going to make it here
actually
or jerry say there is no hell like she
kind of laughed it off when he's like a
mine hell
oh they kind of left him i think that is
a dangerous theology yeah
when you're especially if no kids are
watching you exist no matter
what yeah it's like all of a sudden look
you're going from a to
z no matter what you do everyone does
everything well then why
as a kid why would you like why do i
gotta follow anything why not just
go have fun and enjoy the pleasures of
the sin of this world
and even though they don't call this
heaven look at the poster you see a man
walking on a stairway to the light right
and then above him
is this perfect world with all these
spirits
or is he walking away but i'm just
saying there is a stairway to a light
and then
above him is like a person walking away
that's the great before
he actually wants to go away from him
yeah his whole mission is
get away from heaven go back to earth
i want to spend my life on earth and i'm
going to recruit someone else okay so
this
is a very gnostic theme at its core yeah
so
you know if if um if you guys want to
see
another video we are hopefully by the
time this comes out
have released a video called the gnostic
hollywood gospels
and you should watch that video because
it talks about the truman show
pleasantville
and and these other movies that these
guys have openly claimed they
follow um carl jung philip k dick you
know all of these
these gnostic storytellers in our modern
age
and this is what they're teaching at the
end of the road there's a reason why in
the end of truman he's walking away from
the
world that god created from him and
walking into darkness you're walking
away from the light you're walking into
the darkness
yeah here they are falling to earth who
else fell to earth from heaven
so on the poster it says everybody has a
soul
joe gardner is about to find his you see
any error in that
everybody has a soul yeah so this is
where
it might get a little controversial in
the show um
you you mentioned is there ever an end
is there ever a ceasing to exist
a lot of christians believe there's not
but i want to show
what the bible has to say about a soul
and i'm not going to get into it because
we're actually going to do a whole show
on it
but just to wrap this thing up i just
want to show the big error
in this movie you see joe gardner with
the o of of soul is right there in his
chest and this little ghost popping out
there's a lot of christians that believe
that's the way it is like there's a
little ghost that lives inside you and
he's immortal and
and when you die he never dies
so i want to just read genesis 2 7
where it says and the lord god formed
man of the dust of the ground
and breathed into his nostrils the
breath of life
and man became a living soul so the
thing i want you to focus on is
where did you get that he breathed into
his nostrils
the breath of life and he became a soul
so
a soul has ingredients you got the
breath of life
and you got a body which equals a living
soul man
is a soul he doesn't possess a soul he
doesn't have a soul living in him
so when you break down the breath of
life it's literally spirit
and the greek in the hebrew the word
breath or the word spirit that we see
in english translations in the greek and
the hebrew it is
breath it's ruach or numa numa being you
know you get pneumonia that's about your
lungs and breath
and ruock this is breath of life
he was formed from the dust of the
ground our bodies even animal bodies he
created from the dust of the ground
and you put those two ingredients
together you have a soul now
you can use simple mathematics here what
happens when you remove
either ingredient right you cease to
become a soul
if you have a pile of nails
and you add wood
you got two ingredients you got nails
and you got wood
but you put them together and you have a
wooden box
but if you remove either those
ingredients do you still have a box
nope yeah if you pull out the nails you
got another pile of wood so
how can we say that god created man of
the dust of the ground
and he breathed into the breath of life
but once you breathe that last breath
you're still some kind of immortal being
that floats off and goes to heaven
it just doesn't it's it's not in the
bible from what i see
the james 2 26 says that for as the body
without the spirit is dead
so faith thought works is dead it's
telling you right there when the body
doesn't have the spirit
it's dead because you're removing one of
these ingredients you can't have that
box without
both so the body minus the breath
equals dead this is just like simple
mathematics
dust minus the spirit is dead and job 27
it says all the while my breath is in me
and and the spirit of god is in my
nostrils this is the same thing we saw
in genesis
the breath in his nostrils
the spirit of god is job saying that he
has a little ghost living in his nose
no because breath because spirit is
breath
just like we saw in genesis 2 7 he
breathed into his nostrils the breath of
life
and for anyone who says well you know
the movie is called soul
so we got these two words spirit and
soul we just talked about what the
spirit is it's breath
but ezekiel 18 20 says the soul that
sins
it shall die in ezekiel 18 4 says the
soul that sins it shall die and even in
revelation 16
3 while talking about sea creatures
says every living soul died in the sea
anything any being any body that
has breath inside of it is a living soul
and when you breathe that last the bible
says that
your spirit goes back to god which gave
it that's the breath of life goes back
to god
i like how you read there there are
certain things that will
cease you from living you will die if
you do these things
the wages of sin is death right
galatians 5
20 says idolatry witchcraft hatred
strife sedition
heresies envies murders drunkenness and
all of the things that are
like this of which i tell you before and
i have also told you in times past they
which do such things will
not inherit the kingdom of god so there
is clear evidence that there are certain
things that will keep
your soul from literally being able to
be alive at some point you will die and
that means
dead zero zitch nothing yeah well the
first lie in the garden was
you won't surely die right god said if
you eat that fruit you're going to die
but
the deceiver said if you eat it you
won't die you're going to be like god
you can live forever right um so
where's the hope in this message though
we're saying that the soul can die and
all that
our hope is in the resurrection right
christ said
i'll come again and i will bring you
unto my soul unto me
and in my father's house are many
mansions we're our hope is in that day
when when the trumpet sounds that the
last
trump in the graves open and in the dead
in christ who are they if we all
live who are the dead in christ will
rise first and those
that are you know immortal will put on
immortality
you know what i mean so it doesn't say
that people have immortality outside of
that day john 3 16 said whosoever
believes in him should not perish
but have everlasting life if the wages
of sin is death and the gift of god is
everlasting life
these are very parallel things like
parallel these are very
contrasting things perish death
eternal life you know everlasting life
you cannot live forever without that
gift
and you won't put on immortality and you
won't have right to the tree of life as
revelation says those who keep the
commandments of god have right to the
tree of life
if the punishment for adam and eve
disobeying god was to be separated from
the tree of life that caused
death they no longer had access to the
tree of life
if you don't have access to the tree of
life you can't live
and so one day those who keep the
commandments of god will have right to
the tree of life we're going to put on
immortality and we'll have access
back to that tree of life and the wicked
will not get the gift of life
and they will not put on immortality and
they will not have right to the tree of
life
and therefore no not right now we're
mortal
if you look up a definition of that it
means subject to
death not
but a lot of people say well that's not
eternity you know
you would have to be immortal to not be
subject to death which
the bible says god is the only one who
is immortal
adults love reminding children of that
hey be careful
of this world take it out yeah no but
all these things that we're talking
about you know the biblical concepts
that we know because we study the bible
i think the biggest issue with movies
like this and and others
is that they're opening these this can
of worms right
pop now this child or even this person
this adult has all these
thoughts ideas questions and if it's not
anchored in anything and specifically
for a christian
if it's not if you don't have your
anchor in the word of god you're going
to be swept away with all these ideas
you know why because you don't have that
anchor where's your source of truth
coming from
so i mean that's why we keep having
these discussions
new movies same concept right and movies
are powerful
they're not just playing with words
they're playing with words and sounds
and
things that sear into your memory i mean
i can still
remember things that i saw as a young
child that
literally i can look back in my mind and
i can see it like like i saw yesterday
yeah and that that imagery was burned
into my brain
mixed with all those things so yeah it's
it's a powerful medium i mean we we're
not discounting
that this is a strong way to to
educate or teach a message it's just i
think you really need to be careful of
what is that message that's being taught
and like you said candy brilliantly said
if it's not having some sort of
foundation
or some anchor to truth it's it's
confusion
that's right so that's what we want to
talk about that this movie
is full of error it teaches new age
movement it teaches the immortality of
soul teaches
pre-existence which is mormonism and
islam
and it also teaches an ecumenical idea
that everyone no matter what you believe
even if you believe like carl young that
you know
christ and the antichrist and we we got
to have both
that everyone goes to this great beyond
place
it's just not biblical and we shouldn't
entertain our minds with these things
and that's what we want to
say on this show all the time this is
not good for any christian especially
not good for your children and if you
enjoyed this show if you learned
something tell us about it in the
comment if you disagreed let us know
about that too we love getting
feedback from you guys and make sure you
share this because a lot of people have
been asking for this video
and don't forget to like subscribe hit
that notification bell
and we actually have a study on this if
you go look through our channel for a
vbs
it's we're gonna put the link in the
description but it talks about what
happens when you die
and we're actually gonna do a whole
video on this in the future so we will
see you then god bless you guys
[Music]
you